[Musica]
farmi parlare di soldi quindi questo
tema così in alcuni casi triste di
sabato le tre con questo sole dopo aver
visto la presentazione affascinanti dei
miei colleghi
devo dire che è una sfida difficile
parlerò quindi a slogan per ok
tenterò di parlare a slogan ecco per
fare capire la visione che noi abbiamo
avuto circa 15 anni fa e che abbiamo
messo in pratica credo che sia questo
l'elemento importante di oggi quando uno
una persona di persone hanno una visione
e poi riescono a metterlo in pratica è
sicuramente un successo se si raggiunge
l'obiettivo positivo che si era si era
pensato stavo parlando di impatti
investing che vuol dire sinteticamente
investire dei soldi cercando un ritorno
finanziario come in qualsiasi altro
investimento cercando anche però un
impatto un impatto sociale
oggi di im park in vesti se ne parla
tantissimo per darvi un'idea ogni
nazione all'interno del proprio gruppo
che a ogni ogni sei mesi ogni anno si
incontra per le riunioni del g8 g9 oggi
9 ha sempre al proprio interno un gruppo
che si occupa di impact investing perché
un tema trend che sta andando di moda
impatto sociale è stato più volte
declinato in vari modi purtroppo oggi
per impatto sociale si intende anche
ambientale societario di governance
quindi ha compreso un po tutto
e questo sta facendo perdere secondo noi
la propulsione che dieci anni fa invece
aveva linpac investing per darvi un'idea
soprattutto le grandi corporation
finanziarie americane pensate proprio le
più grandi si stanno occupando nel senso
di questo tema nel senso che stanno
raccogliendo dati tantissimi soldi per
fare investimenti in questo settore
dicendo ai propri investitori da tichy
soldi
noi faremo impatto sociale assicurando
gli stessi rendimenti che avete se
investite in altri settori non è così
non funziona perché se tu vuoi veramente
avere un impatto sociale anche
ambientale non puoi ottenere almeno ad
oggi fra 20 anni magari sì gli stessi
rendimenti che tu ottieni investendo in
altri settori
oppure in altre società molto più
radicate con una lunga storia ecco
questo sta purtroppo facendo questa
teoria sta purtroppo facendo annacquare
la forza propulsiva che noi avevamo
pensato per per l'impatt investing e noi
lo avevamo pensato
parlo di 15 anni fa quindi vi racconto
una storia che poi sia realizzata avendo
questo come come scenario c'erano
fortissime pulsioni sociali
l'immigrazione la disuguaglianza cose
che esistono ancora adesso è il settore
che un tempo era destinato a risolvere
questo che era il settore pubblico nelle
declinazioni come vedete uberto nel
terzo settore non è stato in grado in
quel periodo di andare incontro a questi
nuovi bisogni primo perché mi mancavano
i soldi
lo sapete secondo perché dal nostro
punto di vista mancava anche
l'innovazione il settore privato di
questo nuovo settore che stava nascendo
non gliene fregava niente perchè perchè
loro giustamente il settore privato alle
imprese che lavorano nel settore privato
ricerca nella massimizzazione del
profitto questa è una vecchia è ancora
attuale teoria
d'impresa tutti questi nuovi bisogni che
nel frattempo la cosiddetta fascia
grigia della popolazione che un tempo i
sociologi utilizzavano necessitavano di
nuovi modelli di risposte ai bisogni che
non venivano né risolte da questa parte
né risolti dall'altra parte
allora noi cosa ci siamo detti noi e
altri due o tre pionieri in europa
ok occorrono nuovi modelli come si fa a
creare nuovi modelli di impresa e quindi
fare innovazione
occorrono gli imprenditori sono gli
imprenditori che hanno delle idee che
poi concretizzano in attività d'impresa
bene come si fa ad attrarre questi nuovi
imprenditori in un nuovo settore
secondo noi visto anche la nostra
esperienza passate ci vogliono soldi e
ci vogliono competenze manageriali per
poterli aiutare a crescere e per questo
noi in italia ed altri in europa abbiamo
creato un piccolo fondo di venture
capital un fondo di venture capital in
america li conoscete sono quelli che poi
hanno fatto nascere facebook airbnb
insomma le principali aziende americane
sono quel team di persone che hanno
ottenuto la fiducia dell'investitore
quindi riescono a farsi dare i soldi
dagli investitori e poi hanno delle
competenze manageriali più o meno
importanti che servono per accompagnare
le idee imprenditoriali generalmente di
di giovani noi abbiamo fatto questo
abbiamo raccolto un piccolo fondo e mi
hanno iniziato ad investire ad investire
nella quella che noi chiamiamo
innovazione sociale che per noi è
fondamentale perché se tu vuoi
affrontare determinati bisogni devi
partire dai bisogni fondamento
tali della società
noi vediamo anche moltissime start up
tecnologiche che sono importanti la
tecnologia sta cambiando il modo di
vivere
però per noi e per chi fa impact
investing è molto più importante cercare
di investire in quei progetti in quelle
idee che trasformano il settore nel
senso che trasformano il modello di
business soprattutto in italia ma anche
in europa
il tema dell'innovazione intervento di
giorni voi sapete che anche in italia il
governo sta facendo partire un fondo
innovazione di un bd un miliardo quindi
è tantissima roba sono tantissimi soldi
la roba manzoniana il tema è cosa
facciamo di questi di questi soldi
investiamo esclusivamente in tecnologie
benissimo va bene i colleghi di prima ci
hanno dato un esempio di come si
potrebbe aiutarli investendo dei soldi
creando queste piattaforme
però non è sufficiente soprattutto in
italia si investe in tecnologia per
copiare qualcosa che all'estero si sta
già facendo un mito questo vuol dire che
effettivamente non stiamo cambiando il
sistema
stiamo adottando prendendo le nuove
tecnologie probabilmente per avvicinare
domanda e offerta benissimo ma non è
questo quello che secondo noi serve e vi
faccio degli esempi concreti
graziano gli esempi concreti e il grazie
perché secondo noi occorre utilizzare
come ecco come ho scritto la tecnologia
per ridurre lo spazio per ridurre lo
spazio ad esempio in tema sanitario tra
il medico e il paziente io vedo c noi
veniamo circa 2 up due start up che ci
presentano delle app sanitarie a
settimana che va bene nel senso riduce
la fila
diagnostica diversi ma nessuno finora ci
ha presentato se non dieci anni fa una
nostra idea un nuovo modo per erogare le
prestazioni mediche
questo è quello che serve e che serve
anche oltre alle arpa dei modelli che
modificano l'erogazione dei servizi che
permettano l'inclusione finanziaria che
permettano l'accesso alla sanità di
tutti
solo così secondo noi solo così in parte
se non vogliamo risolvere ovviamente i
problemi del mondo ma solo così tu
riesce a ridurre le disuguaglianze sono
così tu riesci ridurre anche la
disuguaglianza che ormai anche in italia
c'è tra le grandi città e le piccole
città cercando di fare dei modelli che
in cor vino che incorporino l'obiettivo
di raggiungere un impatto per il
territorio e qui faccio
faccio degli esempi concreti noi dieci
anni fa abbiamo fatto partire un
progetto a cui ci hanno creduto in pochi
all'inizio per creare degli ambulatori
medici di altra mi lano in a miano la
sanità si presume che funziona funzioni
bene
noi però volevamo creare degli
ambulatori dove la gente veniva otteneva
delle prestazioni mediche di buonissima
qualità a prezzi affordable già a prezzi
secondo noi giusti noi facciamo la
società che abbiamo creato fa pagare
all
ai nostri utenti 60 euro per singola
visita che è più del ticket a milano il
ticket è di 40 euro ma è un terzo della
visita privata e siamo riusciti a fare
questo sostenendoci anche
finanziariamente nel senso abbiamo
investito abbiamo convinto altri
investitori a investire e siamo riusciti
attraverso il cambiamento del paradigma
attraverso il cambiamento del modello di
erogazione a erogare noi abbiamo circa
150 mila pazienti e novecento medici che
lavorano in questa in questa società a
erogare servizi di moni qualità senza
code in ambienti molto belli apprezza
affordable questo è quello che credo gli
anglosassoni potrebbero chiamare di slap
ti fa poi siamo anche noi le app per il
menu la fila fare qualcosa ma le usiamo
all'interno di un contenitore ben
preciso questo primo esempio quindi
permettere a tutti di accedere alle
visite dentistiche e non si tratta di
filantropia o di donazione a livello
mondiale le donazioni la forma della
filantropia rispetto agli investimenti
va purtroppo è una piccola goccia quindi
la nostra sfida è stata anche quella di
convincere gli investitori chi ha soldi
veri ad investire in questi progetti ad
essere d'esempio per altri che poi
possono tentare di fare quello che noi
stiamo facendo oggi in lombardia
questo progetto riconosciuto come uno
dei più validi nella sanità è nata con
la visione dell'impatto investing grazie
anche a degli investitori che hanno
accettato di dire ok faccio delle cose
che servono accetto un rendimento non
esaltante comunque
un rendimento tra virgolette giusto ma
ogni mezzo che mi permetta di sostenere
un certo grado di rischio
la seconda la seconda sfida che abbiamo
avuto l'inclusione finanziaria
anche qui se io vi dicesse ho in mente
tre o quattro start up fintech italiane
che credo che vista voi siete molto
giovani li conosciate tutte che stanno
facendo delle cose interessanti
permettono l'investimento della del
resto che vi danno nei centri
commerciali o negli esercizi commerciali
di permettono ci permettono di pagare
più velocemente benissimo ma sapete qual
è quale era e quale uno dei problemi
fondamentali in italia l'inclusione
finanziaria di certe strati della
popolazione non solo gli immigrati ma
anche gli italiani
conoscete 23 società che hanno tentato
di fare quello no perché non è da meno
credono adesso mi sono dato la risposta
perché non è così trendy
eppure nel 2008 2009 un ragazzo di 26
anni ci è venuto a proporre questo nuovo
modo di fare l'inclusione che il
microcredito fatto in italiano fatto in
bagno la direction qualche altro paese
in via di sviluppo fatto in paesi
sviluppati che è completamente diverso
dall'altro
nessuno ci credeva abbiamo iniziato noi
mettendoci pochi soldi 100 mila euro
non c'eravamo creduto tanto forse
comunque abbiamo lavorato tantissimo
oggi questa società ha erogato circa 200
milioni di micro credito a persone a
banca ball cioè persone che prima non
avevano un conto corrente bancario vi
sembrerà banale per noi tutti
ma se tu vai in qualsiasi ciccio
commerciale vuoi iniziare qualsiasi
attività e non hai un conto corrente non
ti danno niente
ecco attraverso questa
questa attività economica oggi per micro
ha un capitale sociale ha raccolto circa
10 milioni di equity vuol dire di
capitale di rischio
vuol dire che queste istituzioni che
hanno dato il capitale di rischio
rischiano in questa intrapresa sapendo
di ottenere un rendimento calmierato ma
va bene così perché è un impatto sociale
fortissimo poi io sono anche convinto e
alcune grandi economisti ci stanno
aiutando in questo ragionamento nel
senso che stanno scrivendo già dei libri
anche alcuni economisti italiane che
anche il valore dell'azienda debba
cambiare nel senso che se uno fa questo
tipo di attività si radica
fortissimamente nel territorio nella
comunità in cui si trova questo vuol
dire il che a rischio di default e
rischio di fallimento è molto meno
importante rispetto ad un investimento
tecnologico lo sapete investimento
tecnologico uno ne fa 10 di questi dieci
investimenti due ne vanno bene i
rendimenti sono elevati di altri 8 no ma
è così e o no fa generalmente qui no qui
il valore aumenta anche perché il
rischio è differente se lo fai bene e
quindi il valore ma il valore per me non
è sul valore etico quella è un altra
cosa è il valore economica della società
aumenta e se il valore economico della
società aumenta sarà possibile attirare
nuovi investitori
e se riusciamo e se riuscissimo ad
attrarre nuovi investitori
potremmo si potrà fare ancora di più
questi tipi di attività che come dico
hanno anche l'obiettivo se si riesce di
ridurre delle diseguaglianze 30.000
micro imprenditori hanno ricevuto
microcredito
ma soprattutto sono diventati banca
questo vuol dire che possono andare in
banca aprire dei finanziamenti dei muri
questo è lasciato gli interventi srap
tifi importante per noi
l'altro lo cito perché
unire strumento che abbiamo fatto a
grosseto anche qui secondo noi
importante adesso di sciolino alcuni
dati e faccio il sapientone ma fino a
tre anni fa non sappiamo nulla noi
importiamo 500mila tonnellate di
pomodori dall'olanda dove finalmente il
sole c'è poco e questo perché perché
loro vent'anni 25 anni fa hanno adottato
diverse tecnologie hanno fatto un
sistema di produzione a livello paese
importante noi no
ci sono diverse tecnologie a tecnologia
importante l'idro monica che oltretutto
dal punto di vista ambientale è un
successo perché ti fa consumare un
decimo dell'acqua che rispetto alle
altri tipi di di coltivazione in italia
ci sono solo due o tre esempi
di utilizzo di idroponica ma su
dimensioni piccole quello che noi
abbiamo fatto invece seguendo l'idea di
di una persona di un imprenditore che ce
l'ha presentato e provare a dimostrare
che anche in italia è possibile
investire nella produzione agricola e
non nella trasformazione italia molti
soldi vanno leal trasformazione ma nella
produzione molto pochi noi abbiamo detto
vogliamo dimostrare che è possibile
investire anche nella produzione
agricola cercando di cambiare il modo di
produrre cioè utilizzando queste
tecnologie però utilizzandolo in grande
scala perché in alcuni settori la grande
scala è fondamentale solamente se tu
applichi un processo quindi con le
diverse tecnologie di verso mete di su
larga scala ti puoi permettere di
sostenere dei costi che altrimenti non
ti quando potresti permettere di farlo e
quindi subendo anche all'inizio delle
perdite perché tutti i tuoi corsi si
spalmano su dei processi
diciamo di lungo periodo noi abbiamo
fatto una serie di tredici hanno fatto
una serra di 13 ettari che dovrebbe
essere una delle più grandi in italia
per poi farne se funziona come sta
funzionando per farne altre questi che
vantaggi a torno a dire prima di cercare
di creare anche in italia finalmente un
sistema correndo rischio nel senso che
noi abbiamo raccolto parecchi soldi che
sia una delle start up che ha raccolto
più soldi in italia prospettando un
sogno una visita in pipe un sogno dei
vestito nomi di con sogno ma che se no
non mi danni sono di una visione che è
quella di produrre in italia senza capo
lar caporalato
non so se qualcuno di voi in agosto non
sa cosa fare si si può leggere una volta
a settimana il guardian giornali inglesi
ogni volta c'è un articolo duro
purtroppo giustamente contro l'italia
per il caporalato per la raccolta dei
pomodori altro ecco se questa con questa
iniziativa dovesse andare bene come sta
andando
vorremmo anche dimostrare che è
possibile fare dei pomodori di buona
qualità senza l'utilizzo del caporalato
è un cambiamento di sistema
usiamo poi ambientalmente usiamo terreno
non fertile insomma ci sono degli
elementi molto positivi
questo è questa è la visione che non
avevamo e questi sono un po degli esempi
abbiamo creato 18 muove di nuove su
nuove società questo è stato possibile
in parte per la nostra visione in parte
perché alcuni investitori pionieri
stanno accettando questo nuovo modo di
investire che vuol dire perdere i soldi
perché se dovessimo perdere i soldi non
ci darebbe più i soldi per il nuovo
fondo e quindi si chiuderebbe così qui
belle idee a bravi pacche sulle spalle
ma non è quello che vogliamo fare quello
che vogliamo fare è veramente cercare di
fare innovazione sociale nel senso
corretto del termine nel senso per noi
senso corretto vuol dire come dicevo
prima
vi ripeto cambiare i modelli di
erogazione dei servizi perché i bisogni
sono cambiati perché le persone sono
cambiate perché la società è cambiata e
ci vuole innovazione per quello che ci
vogliono giovani imprenditori che
abbiano l'ambizione questa un'altra
caratteristica secondo me è importante
come vedete io noi vediamo anche
imprenditori che ci presentano le app e
quando li vediamo c'è ap oppure
piattaforma e quando vengono da noi
spaccano il mondo lorenzo andrà miei
soldi fra tre anni sono la nuova
facebook oppure sono
i bimbi purtroppo generalmente non è
così
nonostante l'entusiasmo quando invece
incontriamo degli imprenditori dei
giovani imprenditori che hanno delle
idee che a noi piacciono ecco forse il
mio comun denominatore che non sono
ambiziosi come dovrebbero invece bisogna
essere ambiziosi anche per questi tipi
di attività anche se tu dici lorenzo io
il rendimento più di tot 60 gli dico
ovviamente di no se però valutiamo
insieme è ragionevole perché non devi
essere ambizioso e dobbiamo essere
ambiziosi dovete essere ambiziosi e
soprattutto con i giovani perché se non
sia viziosi non si riesce a creare non
si riescono a creare dei modelli e
quando uno crea un settore nuovo quello
dell'inps
l'impact ha bisogno di dimostrare che
funzioni per dimostrare che funzioni ha
bisogno di modelli e quindi ambiziosi al
massimo quindi il messaggio che voglio
passare oggi che è possibile avere una
visione nuova noi 15 anni fa siamo stati
i pionieri è possibile anche realizzarla
per l'aria realizzarlo occorre il
contributo di tutti occorre il
contributo degli investitori importante
occorre il contributo di professionisti
che sanno gestire e occorre il
contributo di nuove imprendibili le
nuove della nuova imprenditoria
giovanile che accetta la sfida di
occuparsi anche di queste cose
avendo il coraggio di essere ambiziosi e
di confrontarsi con i pari che pensano
solo alle tecnologie grazie
[Applauso]